[Music]
all CCSD leaders and teachers are making
sure the new school year gets off to a
strong start they discussed today
various issues of concern with eight
news now's Victoria Saha one of them
being ongoing Staffing shortages she
joins us in studio with what changes
have been made
the first day of school is just four
days away many parents hope the first
day goes smoothly whether getting your
child to school on time or making sure
they have a teacher the school district
has hired hundreds of employees to fill
in the gaps but they still have ways to
go
the bus driver shortage caused a lot of
panic and worry for parents last year
many complaining about the school bus
being late or not showing up at all for
the 1300 routes the school district was
short 200 drivers but this year they're
only missing 82. those positions won't
be filled by Monday but Amber ride out
the director of operations for
transportation says they're making
adjustments our staff right now are
working for consolidations to see if
there's any routes that we can
consolidate we anticipate being able to
service time and service for the first
day of school Rideout says staff who
have commercial driver's licenses will
be filling in the gaps until they get
more drivers another ongoing issue is
the teacher shortage Ryan Redmond
director of recruitment tells me 1100
were hired this summer with incentives
50 thousand dollar new salary so it went
up about eight thousand dollars from the
new teacher salary from before
um there's a four thousand dollar uh
relocation bonus they're offering all
teachers that that are coming from if
they reside at least 100 miles from
Clark County School District while the
district is working to hire more
teachers thirteen hundred positions
remain open
that number should decrease as the year
goes by because there are still teachers
who are waiting to complete background
checks in order to start working the
district tells me they will hire all
year long Kirsten thank